[Music]
if you guys can believe it it has been
20 years since the Lion King first
roared onto Broadway and tonight we're
celebrating the 20th anniversary with
the original cast and crew
you believe we're here celebrating two
decades of this show that you got to be
a part of I know I can't believe it in
my mind we started this show about three
years ago so just so you know time flies
doesn't it though I am so thrilled to be
here who knew who did it that we could
be here 20 years later this is the
reason why I live in New York City
because the Lion King brought me here
many many years ago and it was my
Broadway debut
[Applause]
since opening on Broadway in 1997 the
stage adaptation of the beloved Disney
classic has become the most successful
musical in history 20 years later it's
still going strong they think at the
time truth be told I wasn't aware of how
amazing this was going to be how special
it was tonight is a little overwhelming
to have him sit there and to kind of
come home today well how's this for a
full circle moment
[Music]
Elton John surprised the crowd joining
the cast on stage for the 20th
anniversary celebration I wasn't able to
be here for the 15th anniversary and
it's been such an important part of my
life it's open the doors so many doors
for me and it was just great to see
everybody Julie Taymor Tim Rice Heather
Headley it was in the original cast
it was a great get-together and very
meaningful but could the Rocket Man join
forces with Beyonce in the Lion King
live-action remake what do you think of
Beyonce as Nala I'm incredibly flattered
I'm incredibly flattered I was like Oh
fiance it's not alright so I I think the
Beyonce's gonna do an amazing job
needless to say okay anyone else well I
will happily sit down to watch her do
anything I'm sure she doesn't need any
help but if she does she can wean on
single ladies